le ministère de l'intérieur l'a annoncé
vendredi
l'unique centre de déradicalisation de
france va définitivement fermer
créé en septembre 2016 l'établissement
était censé réinsérer des individus en
voie de radicalisation
au total le centre de pontours n'y aura
reçu neuf personnes mais aucune n'avait
suivi le programme jusqu'à son terme
chez les habitants si l'heure est au
soulagement les avis ne restent pas
moins mitigé sur une bonne chose parce
que c'était pas vraiment apprécié de la
population
moi j'habite si ce n'est devant 11
derrière eux et quelque part je voyais
bien ce centre faire la mission dont il
dont on le destine et voilà je pense
qu'il faut soigner ces gens là il ya
toujours une appréhension comme quoi
c'est des gens qui sont susceptibles
d'être dangereux mais bon je viens on
vivait avec ça me laisse un petit peu
indifférente
par contre on aurait le souci
éventuellement de savoir ce que ce
centre va devenir ce qu'il va devenir
c'est justement la principale
interrogation des riverains trois jours
après l annonce de la fermeture
définitive
et à ce propos les habitants de beaumont
en véron ne manque pas d'idées il
faudrait que la même chose qui a eu
pendant un certain nombre d'années des
gens qui viennent pour faire des
formations éventuellement de mettre des
micros qui qui pourraient être logées
dans ce dans ce château de contourner
par exemple une maison pour des anciens
ou des choses comme ça où un centre de
vacances parmi les pistes évoquées une
reconversion du site avec l'accueil de
mineurs isolés étrangers